so one of the most common requests I've
been getting from you all is to explain
the Marvel movie rights who owns which
characters is there overlap between
characters besides Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver and so in this video I'm
gonna be attempting to answer that
question but what we're gonna do in this
video and future videos on this subject
is we're gonna be sticking to the
studio's meaning that in this video
we're gonna be focusing on Sony and
spider-man in future videos we're gonna
be focusing on twentieth Century Fox and
the properties they own and then just
kind of going from there so in order to
make sense of this so what we're gonna
be doing is we're gonna be jumping back
to 1985 and we're gonna have a bit of a
discussion on why Marvel chose to dive
into the movie scene in the first place
in 1978
Superman was released as a feature film
and was wildly successful at the time to
be quite frank and so a lot of eyes were
looking towards Marvel the question was
when is Marvel going to produce a
feature film based on one of their
characters now Marvel also saw the
success of Superman and so Marvel wanted
to do the same thing they wanted to
create a feature film the problem here
was that Marvel just didn't have the
financial support they didn't have the
financial backing to actually launch
their own feature film and so what they
did is they I guess began offering the
ability for companies to license their
characters and films starting in 1985
and the first character they did this
with was spider-man now initially when
they offer this up in 1985 there weren't
a lot of people who were biting and the
reason why was because by this time
Superman 3 had come out and a lot of
people looked at Superman 3 as just a
dismal example of a superhero film
people thought it was a terrible film
and so people were just sort of burned
out they didn't really want to have
anything to do with it and so while
nobody was really biting at the option
to basically license a spider-man film
there was one studio that was and this
studio was actually called canon films
and it was an independent film studio
and so what happened when the deal was
struck between Marvel and Canon films
Marvel basically would allow Cannon
Films to pay two hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars and for this price
canon films would be able to control all
aspects of the spider-man film they
would control everything from the
initial screenplay all the way up to the
distribution that would be done by
Columbia Pictures
and so what ended up happening here is
that in 1990 while the idea for kenan
films to produce a film was still an
idea the problem was that Kenan Films
was going bankrupt and so what canon
films did is they basically sold off the
rights to spider-man to a company called
Kuroko films now Karaka films was again
another independent film studio and what
Karaka films actually did is they hired
James Cameron to write the script for
the spider-man film but the issue was
that again much like canon films in 1995
Kuroko films was going bankrupt
and so the problem was that by this time
what Karaka films was also going
bankrupt and Spiderman was just kind of
held in limbo in terms of the films and
whether or not one was going to be made
Marvel was finally for bankruptcy and so
at this point the spider-man rights
basically reverted back to Marvel or at
least it seemed to be that way and so
the lawyers from Marvel basically
started analyzing marvel's assets the
question being if Marvel now owns the
rights to spider-man in film form again
if those rights have reverted back to
them and it's currently 1995 ten years
after they initially offered the rights
up and nobody was offering then maybe
like Hollywood and in society as a whole
has moved towards the direction to where
they really want to see more superhero
films now they're kind of ready to see
what Marvel has to offer the problem was
when the lawyer sat down and they
started looking at the various assets of
Marvel and they looked at the film
rights while initially it appeared as
though Marvel had had owned the rights
to spider-man they actually didn't that
what Marvel had done is they had
basically started throwing the
spider-man rights to anybody who would
buy them and the result was that MGM
Viacom Columbia Pictures and Warner
Brothers in addition to various other
studios all claimed rights to the
spider-man film and so over the course
of about four years of legal battles or
so ultimately Columbia Pictures which
was a subsidiary of Sony came out on top
as the owner of the spider-man rights
and so this ultimately led to Sony being
the ones that were able to produce
spider-man film related content now
here's the kicker in terms of the
contract as far as I've been able to
figure out what was basically outlined
here was that Sony owns the rights to
spider-man
spider-man's various villains and
related property
now the related property segment is
ambiguous at best because neither Sony
or Marvel has basically come out and
said here are the characters that Sony
has the rights to make characters to or
make films to I'm sure Sony knows who
they are and model knows who they are is
simply we don't know who they are and so
what we know the Sony owns the film
rights to spider-man we don't know if
Sony or Marvel owned the film rights to
Spider Woman we don't know if Sony or
Marvel which one of those two owns the
rights to the characters that were
created that were basically designed or
different versions of spider-man after
the terms of the contract were settled
these are things we don't know and so we
for example we have no idea whether or
not Marvel can make a film based on
Miles Morales these are the things that
we just don't know we have no real idea
here it could very well be that when the
contract was laid out they were
specified in such a way that Sony has
the rights to all spider-man related
content in film form which includes any
future related spider-man content these
are things that we just have no idea
about and so until either Marvel or Sony
comes out and says this is the case
we're really just kind of speculating at
best the only thing we know for certain
is that Sony owns the rights to the
sinister six to the spider-man
properties on may Mary Jane Watson those
various characters Gwen Stacy and so on
we just don't know how far beyond that
it goes with that being said I hope it
makes sense it's kind of weird it's it's
really kind of crazy but again this is
all just very murky cloak-and-dagger
kind of stuff here so I will catch you
guys later peace